دايما من الخرطوم ما ينضم الينا جيرمن
ميهو المتحدث باسم الصليب الاحمر فيه
السودان اهلا بك سيد جيرمان معنا وضع
انسان صعب اذا في اكثر من منطقه في
السودان ضعنا في الصوره
شكرا للاستضافه انا اتحدث الان اليكم من
الخرطوم
حيث انا هنا منذ بضعه اشهر الوضع سيء
للغايه الناس يشعرون
بالرعب
بسبب الاقتتال الذي بدا بالامس واستمر
ليله الامس وحتى اليوم وما زال القتال
مندلعا في الخرطوم وفي مدن كثيره في
السودان فالوضع سيء للغايه
والاقتتال ما زال جاريا في المناطق
المزدحمه بالسكان مثل الخرطوم
والناس المدنيون لا يستطيعون الحركه وهناك
طلبه عالقون في المدارس الان وهناك اناس
يتوجهون الى المطار
منهم في المطار ما زالوا عالقين الى الان
منذ صباح الامس والكثيرون الان
يشعرون بالخوف والرعب الشديد بسبب هذا
الوضع وكما تعلمون نحن الان في شهر رمضان
والكثيرون يصومون وهذا يجعل الامر مقلقا
اكثر واكثر طيب الصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر ايضا كان قد يعني كانت هناك دعوه
المكونات المختلفه في هذا النزاع فيها
السودان الى الالتزام بالقانون الدولي
الانساني ما القصد في هذه الجزئيه
بالامس اللجنه الدوليه لصليب الاحمر
وجهت نداء لكل الاطراف المشاركون في
القتال في السودان
وقالت ان عليه من يحترم القانون الانساني
الدولي
ونحن الان لدينا اولويات
للسماح بالمنظمات الانسانيه ان تعمل
فان لم تستطع ان تتحرك هذه المنظمات فمن
المستحيل لهم ان يصلوا الى المدنيين وان
يصلوا الى الجرحى وان يقدموا المساعدات
الاوليه وان ينقلوا المصابين الى
المستشفيات نداؤنا ومناشدتنا ايضا متعلقه
بالتسهيل
لسائقين سيارات الاسعاف لكي يستطيعوا
الحركه لكي يستطيعوا توفير الرعايه الصحيه
ايضا هناك قلق لدينا ينتابنا بشاننا
المعتقلين من الطرفين لذلك نقول للطرفين
يجب معامله المعتقلين معامله انسانيه هذه
المناشده التي وجهناها بالامس عن عبر
قناتكم ان اتحدث مره اخرى
للطرفين
وللمسؤولين من كلا الطرفين بانه من المهم
ان يسمحوا للمنظمات الانسانيه بالعمل
والتحرك وان يعملوا كل ما بوسعهم لحمايه
المدنيين وان يسمحوا لسيارات الاسعاف
بالتحرك بحريه لكي ينقذوا المصابين طيب
بانتظار الاستجابه لهذه النداءات هل من
تدابير خاصه او طارئه تتخذونها لحمايه
المدنيين
دمان ريستون
سوليه كثيره على عاتقنا
والمسؤوليه الاولى المتعلقه بحمايه
المدنيين
ولذلك فالمقاتلون هم من يجب ان يتخذ هذه
الاجراءات لحمايه المدنيين لان العمليات
العسكريه التي مندلعه الان في الاماكن
المزدحمه بالسكان اذا فالمسؤوليه هي على
عاتقي المتقاتلين وبالنسبه
للجنه الدوليه لصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر
عليهم ايضا مسؤوليات بحمايه المدنيين
وحمايه اولئك الذين توقفوا عن القتال اما
لانهم اصيبوا او لانهم اعتقلوا اذا
فباختصار نحن نذكرهم بمسؤولياتهم
الجيش الوطني عليه مسؤوليه حمايه المدنيين
وان يسمحوا لمنظمات الانسانيه ان تمارس
مهامها لكي تقدم المساعدات لمن هم محتاجون
بحسب خبراتكم سيد جيرمن هل تتوقعون
استجابه فوريه وملموسه
كلجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر ونامل ايضا
للاطراف السودانيه
ولمن يشاركون في القتال الان بان يفهموا
ويتفهموا دعوتنا ومناشدتنا وان يقدموا
المساعده لنا بتسهيل عملنا ولكل المنظمات
الانسانيه لكي تستطيع التحرك ولكي تفعل
افضل ما بوسعها بغيه حمايه المدنيين
خلال هذه العميلات العسكريه نامل لرسالتنا
ان يتم تلقيها وان يتم اتخاذ الاجراءات
الفوريه من قبل هؤلاء الذين هم يقاتلون
ليس فقط في الخرطوم لوحدها بل في كل مكان
يندلع فيه القتال وذلك لحمايه المدنيين
وتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه لهم عن طريق
المنظمات الانسانيه العامله هناك
طيب ماذا عن قنوات التواصل سيد جيرمن
قنوات مباشره ربما مع الاطراف المختلفه في
السودان لتقديم هذه
المساعدات هل تجدون اي صعوبه في ذلك في ظل
هذا الظرف المشتعل والمرتبه
بعد القتال منذ الامس بصراحه كان الامر
عصيبا جدا علينا وصعبا على اللجنه الدوليه
لصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر السوداني كان الامر صعبا
علينا فيما يخص الحركه وتقديم المساعده
لمن هم بحاجه الى الدعم لقد كان الامر
صعبا جدا ولهذا السبب نحن ننتهز هذه
الفرصه لندعو كل الاطراف المشاركه فيه هذا
القتال لكي يتخذوا كل الاجراءات اللازمه
لكي يقوموا بتسهيل عمل المنظمات الانسانيه
لكي يقوموا بالوصول الى الناس
وبطريقه تحترم القانون الانسانيه الدولي
والا فسيكون هناك امور اصعب واكثر تفاقما
اشكركم تماما من الخرطوم السيد جيرمن
مواهب المتحدث باسم الصليب الاحمر في
السودان